[Music]
this machine is the lateral pull down to
adjust the thigh pad you pull the yellow
pin out and place in the most
comfortable position
to change the weight you pull the yellow
pin out and place in your selected
weight you can also add the 2.5
increment in to add more weight
there are three hand positions for this
machine undergrip
shoulder width and a wide overhand grip
you will then choose your grip and sit
comfortably under the thigh pads and
begin the movement
in order to perform the movement you
want to bring the elbows down towards
the ground keeping the head and chest
upright ensuring that your shoulders are
retracted back it's important to allow
the arms to extend fully to get a full
range of movement before bringing the
arms back down towards the ground
Dismount the machine you will slowly
release the bar back up removing
yourself from under the thigh pad so
that the weight hits the stack
comfortably
foreign
[Music]